هذه هي هافانا الصغيره او ليتل هافانا
صوره مصغره لمدينه مهاجرين تركوا بلدهم
الام كوبا واسيسو مجتمعا جديدا في قلب
ميامي
يتحدث اللغه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
الى الحكومه اعطت الكثير من الاموال لدول
اجنبيه
في محل تجاري التقينا بابا كان اول من صنع
قميص المزارع الكوبي المعروف باسم
كوبافيرا ويقر انا ليتل هافانا منطقه
سياحيه لكنه متخوف من ركود اقتصاديه وتضخم
سيؤثر على مدخوله لذا فهو متحمس للتصوير
الشاشه
باذيه الركود خلال الاسابيع او الاشهر
المقبله
حيث انه اذا فشلنا فهذا سيؤثر على الجميع
تماما مثل اثر لعبه الدومينو نعرف ان كل
الدول بما فيها الاوروبيه ستصاب بالركود
ما هو ملحوظ في هذه الانتخابات وان كل
معسكر متمسكن بارائه فالناخب الذي يصوت
للجمهوريين يرى ان البلاد تسير في الاتجاه
الخاطئ والذي سيصوت للديمقراطيين يرى ان
البلاد محاصره والديمقراطيه في خطر وتبقى
حاله التشردم والانقسام طاغيه وسينعكس هذا
على صناديق الاقتران
[موسيقى]
العربيه مامي فلوريدا